Amanda's with us in West Virginia hey
Amanda how are you music better than I
deserve
how can I help I am concerned with a
decision I made to transfer to the
school that's out of state I came here
with the intent to blow another academic
Common Market which means I can get
their in-state tuition for the major I
was pursuing however I decided not to
pursue that major and I found the major
I would like to pursue
however I'd be paying their out-of-state
and for this semester alone it looks
like I'm more in thirty thousand and we
need to do that for the next few years
no thank you that's what I'm saying
so there is them school back in my home
state that offers that major I was just
debating whether to move out of the
school again and and go to school and
State yeah definitely you're not getting
anything for the money you're paying the
only money they don't the money you're
paying got you nothing except to live in
a different state
it didn't get you a better education it
didn't get you more education it can get
you anything and you're going in debt
just to live in a different state
because you don't want to go backward on
this decision now what I am hearing is
this you change your decision about
every 20 minutes and you've got to stick
with a plan kiddo
so you move back and you stick with this
major and you graduate don't change
again quit changing horses in the middle
of stream it's gonna cost you your
degree and your money what are you
studying for media interactive design
for media creating graphics and
animations for various media outlets and
it was tronic with surviving yeah okay
I might broaden that a little bit to
where you could have some digital
application with that because the number
of jobs that do what you're talking
about just a handful in the entire
nation
and so I mean like three people in every
city do it in television and a few more
in major cities and where there are
networks and so forth but if you get in
a digital situation where you can start
to build digital interaction websites
for companies you don't have to be in a
broadcast scenario you probably would be
more employable and probably make more
money so I probably broaden that
don't-don't-don't study something that's
so nuanced that the job market on the
other side is very very limited if I'm
understanding what you're saying you
know you're developing like lower thirds
on the TV show and that sort of thing
and stuff we do that here we've got
people here that do that but we're an
unusual company and that we do
broadcasting so but if you had a web
application of that or a digital
application of that in some way
probably broaden your income chances as
well as your overall job prospects so
hey good question and just whatever you
do Matt you just just moving around so
it's killing you that's what I'm
observing so yeah you don't stay out of
state just to get a degree and pay I
mean just to get the same degree you
could get it back home and pay four
times more for it there's no there's no
logic to that at all especially when
you're going in debt to do it if you're
paying cash for it I guess you can have
a discussion about it but you're not and
it's just creating a major nightmare for
you the 30-year old version of you is
going to hate the 22 year old version of
you if you stay on this track so just
don't do it please don't do it